that's right okay so you know what i
love about professional athletes
they're usually so much more than an
athlete right they're multi-talented
they're multi-dimensional and doing so
much for their communities
and darren waller star titan of our las
vegas raiders
is one of those athletes i caught up
with him to see what he's up to
off-season
off the field and in the booth hot mike
today
hot mike today hey darin welcome to las
vegas now
hi how are you doing good good this is
your las vegas now debut time to have
some fun
let loose it's the off season yeah
what is um a day in the life of darren
wallace look like
um it looks like waking up uh with
meditation and prayer looks like reading
in the morning
doing some writing i'm doing some
stretching
i'm getting a massage something to get
those nagging injuries from the season
out of the way
working on music in some order you sing
a little bit too
yeah a little bit of singing hope that
you read in between the lines
pray for god i mean i make uh
hip-hop music i'm influenced by a lot of
different genres
in the music that i make but i got a
project i put out called better call
wall in 2017 which is my first one
and then wall street which people know
more which came out
on my birthday in september of 2019 and
those are
can be streamed anywhere that you stream
music and then i will be having another
project on the way probably in spring
just in the mixing and mastering stages
right now
and then adding to the list of talents
and hobbies you are also now a podcast
host
yes uh yes i'm you're trying to take my
job
i'm not taking your job we're we're just
winging it but yes
me with my as my middle coach donnie
starkin's idea shot of donnie
and you know we just kind of roll with
it we rise
we overcome comeback stories really is
just
highlighting uh people and we think that
the most
impressive or the most meaningful thing
you can do is to you know fall down and
get back up we're gonna have a mixture
of all kinds of people
athletes um you know yoga instructors
motivational speakers businessmen
business women so uh
we're doing it for all walks of life
just so people out there know that
whatever they're doing that they can
you know draw some similarities from the
people that we're talking to is the
first episode your story your comeback
story
it could be i would just say stay tuned
um go to the link in my bio on instagram
check out comebackstories.com and you'll
have everything you need to know from
there can you just give a little bit of
an introduction not the whole story
because i want people to tune in
and you know catch up on you but just
give people an idea
i mean growing up you know i was very
confused
about my identity it just went to all
kinds of things and especially you know
drugs and alcohol that was a way for me
to
make friends and also to you know numb
my feelings and all the other
anxieties that i had i feel like
everything in my life that is
you know changed for the better and
there's a positive and it's an asset
it's come from me like going against the
grain like going doing what the opposite
of what other people are doing
and yeah being okay with being different
and you know being sober in vegas is
about as different as it comes when you
ask
people so i'm okay with that so this is
your first
season your first time living in vegas
what do you think about the city
i love vegas there's a whole lot to
offer i mean the strip of course that's
what everybody knows but
i like you know the areas surrounding
all the places you can go eat
the art i'm a fan of the arts district
you know i love seeing
all the different views uh trails hikes
you know i'm a big fan of vegas and all
that it has to offer
all right and now your favorite vegas
memory
i know you haven't had a lot of time to
make them and let's not
do a football memory okay i would say i
have my family
in for christmas got to show them uh
how somebody building a community what
i'm going to be in uh i've got to
you know show them some nice restaurants
i've got to see limsey
red rock things like that drive around
see the stadium
so just having them here because i never
thought i would be here living
and it's amazing to be here just to have
them there to share it was probably my
favorite memory
oh man it's it's the christmas outfits
for
[Laughter]
like his me like i feel like i want to
know more you know absolutely and it's
just one of those stories i've heard it
a few times from him
and it just never gets old it moves me
every time and it's obviously still
being written he's still so young and
has a lot more good to do in the world
so keep up with darren on social media
come back stories the podcast drops next
week so stay tuned for that
and we're also talking about his
foundation apparently kendall tenney you
know
our co-host he's on the board for that
foundation i know i know small world
right
and you can go to darrenwaller.org to
find out how he's helping
at-risk youth who have who are going
through the same problems that
he did in the past so and oh next friday
our big game show i'll be sharing part
two of that interview
where we talk football duh